all right we've got a great show we have
max rose and jackie coms here but first
up he is the blogger of the weekly dish
on sub stack whose notebook is out on a
limb selected writing is 1989-2021
andrew sullivan
[Music]
hello sir
i will you know me
i was never afraid of it
i don't want to give a bad message that
we're shaking heads but i mean you know
you have hiv we've shared a joint i know
i know it's really nerve-wracking i mean
a marijuana cigarette not a
anyway
we do we love we love our weed speaking
of that i heard you on a podcast
say that you have a notebook called high
ideas
ideas ideas ideas okay same idea um
i i of course my whole life is a
notebook called high ideas uh what i
want to know from you is what percentage
of them
when you go back and read them sober
still good
about three out of ten
really yeah yeah no i i'm that's low it
is low i mean i i i as a writer i find
smoking weed really helpful not before i
write i'm always right sober but when
you write something and you smoke a
little joint afterwards your mind your
ego
depresses a little bit and you begin to
look at your work and you say well maybe
that's just crap
and some of them you're right i've
looked back and it's like open a ketchup
restaurant
what the [ __ ] does that even mean you
know but i i have a what i call a
bicameral mind like a bicameral
legislation if i have an important
decision i think about it sober i think
about its
high
if the two bodies can agree on
legislation then i will sign it into law
the two sides have to agree
your ego can get attached to crap
because it's your crap exactly and what
we do is it gets you a little bit away
from right so you're actually able to
look at this you're objectively you kill
your own children which is what all
writers have to do you have to and and i
must say
andrew you're just killing it lately
you're on this substance first of all
this is your 27th time
on this show
the the best
it is a record
you hold you have the crown
and the best part of my job
really is talking to the smartest people
and of course this is america they're
kind of hard to come by
although i must say our staff i think
does a brilliant job finding finding
them but there's a reason why you're the
champ
because i just find you always that you
know that what this country lacks so
much is common sense and perspective and
being lucid
this place you're at now sub stack
right
you were at new york magazine
but you kind of quit them because
newsrooms right now have become a place
where
you used to be able to fire by the
editor
or the owner
now you're fired because the woke in the
newsroom right
you have to conform to the one true
opinion or they don't even want you in
the building
it's a complicated thing because
actually i was fired i was given four
days notice i was nominated for pulitzer
one year and the next year fired not for
anything i wrote
because i wasn't going to completely go
along
with their work agenda they knew that
they knew that i don't know what they
were thinking that's who i am anyway i
don't know why it's so terrible to have
someone in a magazine or in a complete a
mix of things to have someone a
dissenter in a magazine it's fun right i
mean that's the whole point i grew up
wanting to debate wanting to argue i had
a big irish catholic family we thought
about everything what was the problem
afterwards we got together we had a nice
drink we were totally cool about it and
it's not even like you're very
conservative
please i mean you wrote the original
article about gay marriage in 1989
here comes the groom yeah it's in your
book it's brilliant i mean you were so
far ahead of your time on so many of
these things but i mean again it's the
common sense thing i feel like you have
perspective
i think you and i agree on so many
things like who's crazier the left or
the right the right
right there you should be allowed in the
newsroom
is that but
is it
if the editors are responding to social
media social media twitter right is what
creates these online mobs that create
this pressure on the editors to fire
individual writers even if the editors
are fine with the writer and the real
problem with this is not so much the
work in the online media because they
are awful and they should be ignored but
they aren't it's the point of the people
running these institutions liberal
institutions universities magazines
newspapers they don't have the balls to
say no
we will we do believe in a plurality of
views we are going to defend unpopular
writers free speech means nothing
you